I am always proud to support president  Trump Judy I'm so grateful for the way  he led our country with his America  First policies I miss him very much  being our President and so do a lot of  people and I do I say all the time I  really feel like he won the state of  Georgia and I feel like he won the state  of Georgia now  is there a factual basis there no but  she guys she feels it and I do think he  won the 2020 election but you want to  know something it's okay for me to say  that because a lot of people feel the  same way right  this is actually super important  they justify their investigations and  their claims about the 2020 election by  saying lots of people feel this way lots  of people believe this  but the reason that lots of people feel  that way and believe it  is because people like Marjorie Taylor  green told them that it's true